you use that the word last time
with pat on the zoom interview and you
said and i looked up the definition it
says it's the behavior and emotion
spread spontaneously
through a group or group think and then
you also use the the terminology which i
had heard before courtesy of eminem
which was the terminology called
munchausen syndrome yes right
which um he basically said he was a do
you remember when he talked about his
you know why he hates his mom so much
for all of our hip-hop fans out there oh
she used to do this that's his whole
thing he's like why he hate i'm sorry
mama i never meant to hurt you yeah i
didn't know that he was a victim of
months hundred syndrome that whole thing
tyler you might know this you're a rap
guy
and that's where you deliberately used
to know the line by heart there you go
buddy uh and so you deliberately produce
symptoms of illness so that people care
for them so you're the center of
attention are you saying that's kind of
what's going on with the lgbtq is you
want to it's almost like don't do as i
do do as i say like i'm identifying as
lbg uh lgbtq or whatever it is or trans
but i'm not really
doing it behind closed doors so let me
let me yeah let me build on that so
thank you for that question uh in 2010
i wrote a paper which i published in a
medical journal
uh it was on munch hausen syndrome by
proxy and so let me let me describe
and you could probably pull out that
paper uh
munch hausen syndrome is exactly what
you said adam this is when i feign
a medical illness in order to garner
empathy and sympathy that's munchausen
syndrome munch housing syndrome by proxy
is even more diabolical this is when i
take someone who's under my care
my biological child my pet my elderly
parent and i harm them so that i can
garner the empathy and sympathy by proxy
so by harming the kid then everybody
comes to me oh poor you poor parent you
have this child so the a lot of the
transgender craze from the parental
perspective is a form of much housing by
proxy right look at me i have a child
who has you know gender identity issues
so it's but in that sense by proxy it's
that paper that i published in 2010
that then led me in the parasitic mind
to uh diagnose the victimology currency
that we see today in society as a form
of collective munch housing and
collective munch housing by proxy the
idea being that it is no longer
the mechanism by which we ascend the
hierarchy through meritocracy right i am
the most accomplished professor
therefore i should get the big reward
now it's am i a bigger victim than both
of you right and if i am then i win
right so feel bad for me feel bad for
him you should feel the baddest for me
exactly so so now so i warned now nearly
two decades ago i've been warning people
that once these type of parasitic ideas
take hold in the universities it's the
end of science now i don't mean to be
the guy sitting telling you i told you
so but i told you so so and let me
explain how it manifests itself in
academia you could no longer now apply
for a scientific grant without
submitting as part of your grant what's
called the diversity inclusion and
equity statement which i call in the
book die
because that's the acronym right
diversity inclusion equities where
meritocracy goes to die literally why
because now we no longer adjudicate
whether we're going to give you 300 000
to do your research based on the merit
of your scientific research
is your die statement woke enough now
what is the die statement
uh are you going to be hiring uh
transgender people of color
is your methodology going to incorporate
indigenous ways of knowing it
it if it defies even godzad's satire and
caricatures right what does it mean to
do indigenous way of knowing there is no
indigenous way of knowing there's only
the scientific method right there is no
lebanese jewish way of doing
evolutionary psychology there's just
evolutionary psychology there is no uh
is it assyrian or syrian assyrian yes
there is no assyrian mathematics there
is just mathematics that's what makes
the scientific methods such a democratic
epistemology it allows us to keep our
personal identities at the door right
you just do math you just do chemistry
you just do psychology but now we're
reverting back to the epistemological
dark ages whereby whether i get a grant
or not is literally encoded in terms of
how woke i am i have a colleague of mine
at mcgill he's a physical chemist he's
been denied two grants he's a very
serious scientist
he actually came to dinner when jordan
peterson came to montreal two weeks ago
he also came to dinner with us this
gentleman his name is pat
he was denied two grants as a physical
chemist
by the way he's a brown person i mean
much browner than we are i mean he's
from he's from india okay so he he
checks the box of person of color
he's been denied a because he won't play
the walk game so imagine how outrageous
it is that in the 21st century whether
we give scientific grants to people is
not based on the scientific merit of
their grants but based on how woke they
are it's grotesque it's unbelievable so
if you like this clip and you want to
watch another one click right here and
if you want to watch the entire podcast
click right here
[Music]